[Music]
what's happening
[Music]
you
any luck
[Music]
well
for right now if you want sound asleep
[Music]
there it is
[Music]
all right
I'm gonna go
here we go Eileen oh man I got my head
let's see let's see here we go right
here let's start up
[Music]
you
here we go here we go here we go
[Music]
here we go there it is
[Music]
all right so let's get into it so panel
takes Edinboro we did that in 2012 right
so the way to started was I worked with
[Music]
director Brian Ferguson in Chicago and
and when I was filming when I was
getting ready to film animal furnace
I had him film me to do this thing
called a week to kill and so we filmed
my week leading up to filming in Chicago
there filming in New York I feeling
didn't I did a bunch of sets in Chicago
and kind of made the rounds
I think that's available on vimeo and
maybe youtube a week to kill it has a
favorite my favorite uh my favorite
scene in there's this guy disease comes
up has this freestyle that he was just
so it was I guess this is why I like
zippers wraps up sighs cuz he he said
some words because some you didn't
really but he had so much conviction
Carlos Chicago everybody now if I wasn't
all stay I'll be free stop engine and if
some other people popped in and it's a
it's a it's a wild scene so that was
that
so I did the Edinburgh Festival in
I did it in 2011 for the first time
French festival you performed for a
month you do a show every day your own
solo show every day and you do a bunch
of other you know side sets and shows
they had so many shows going on in a
month in this area you perform a lot and
it was it was really dope to one ceases
the different concepts people were doing
as performers because it wasn't it was
some people that just did straight-up
stand-up shows I was one of but a lot of
those shows had things and a lot of
production values and you know all these
times out cues and so it was it was real
cool to see it so I had a good time
there got nominated for Best Newcomer
Award and and it kind of led to me
getting booked another European mark
like I did I did
London the next year but kind of that
diss about the places and so we decided
to film out there for a month
Ryan had the idea and so I said yeah
let's do it
I reached out to I wanted to do it
myself I reached out to Judd Apatow to
help produce it and so he put up half of
the money I put up half the money
because I was I was I wanted to gamble
but not fully gamble
and so Judd helped me out with it which
is great because at the time I wasn't
really hands-on with a lot of projects
this is my first I wasn't really super
involved in the Edit just team handled a
lot of the post on this and dealing with
all the footage and really they were
super instrumental in this project
getting completed and done so thanks to
them for that because if it was just on
you know me I was yeah I couldn't really
so even watching this I might not make
it all the way through but luckily we
got Last of Us and luckily I won't get
copyrighted because we own this so no no
algorithm will come so the sort of
rescue for little ol Viacom CBS nobody
you know I know sorry sorry about that
yesterday
bio-cop CBS 4 playing my own [ __ ] what
was I thinking
who I was be some type of maniac of
something playing my own special without
getting the heads-up anyway so here we
go let's uh let's start out hannibal
takes Adam bro
[Music]
welcome to comedy at the Knitting
Factory going to Scotland for a month I
leave tomorrow
oh I gotta go work yeah I can't no
where's my snare where's my snare yes
guy I got no stare in my headphones hold
up
where's my can I get more hi-hat can I
get I get can I get more hi-hat on the
headphones
what's up nope nope nope nope
Oh what's up you know what I'm gonna get
into Last of Us you know what last of us
last of us is a actually I was talking
to Chris murk who directed the special
and he talked about this game diving in
and how it was pretty insane I have Xbox
one and half for a while just it's not a
step very you know some people it's a
very serious division we had for Xbox I
just didn't get ps4 it wasn't nothing
against it it's just you know nothing
I spy Xbox so but this game had so much
[Music]
is the same this seems pretty Wow
so I said you know what I would get the
ps4 and I'll use that to buff we're
talking about my old stand-up stuff so
here we go last of us - I didn't play
the first one oh yes please
is it the plane things Oh what I thought
I wanted to play disc see Oh
after that it is all right okay see
honey
notice how you get the disc out of here
all right
eject eject eject eject let me see
boom nope Viterbo there we go
first a Playstation all right yeah dad
okay
[Music]
[Music]
what is the plaintiff
here we go here we go here we go let's
see
alright that's a harrowing opening image
what
shadow biscuit boy 45 okay
text-to-speech speak language what's the
options that American spit shadow voice
again Brazil ero okay let's just keep it
just keep it like that we sighs the
Marquez and today 50 corners of your
screen okay
wait is this like this an attack on me
wait wait I wish your screen like
playboy okay it's well this is right
this television I got five morning
that's done I see what y'all doing
this is continuing
kind of features fly you know I'm gonna
have to turn that notification off you
love that's trying to really got trying
to really be seen out here and so
you already see but you know she's
distracted
[Music]
what is this
[Music]
[Music]
okay what I thought not hail naw hell no
aw I was called out prayer request to
followers and they sit in that I can't
do it it's just too it's too much for my
brains if to focus okay
peace peace thank you right see peace
[Music]
y'all
[Music]
you know this is really there we go
there we go
[Music]
all right okay boom alright back to the
game
shut up Naughty Dog here so I don't know
I was it boat let's see was crying
nice anybody
all right the main story still download
our okay what what let me know what to
check what difficulty level you also do
what what are you doing then you know
where to check let's see yeah I did not
play the first one of these I don't have
a I just got a PlayStation the other day
just for this initially I I know I said
I was gonna do I won't tell you how this
concept happened so I will talk about
Hannibal takes Adam bro but then I
decided I didn't want to talk about my
county and I've kind of locked myself
and said it's doing that and I announced
it so I told my cousin I said hey I'm
just gonna play the video game instead
he's like no don't do that I want to
hear about how to take that and so I
said alright I'll do both so that's
really why we're here like this because
if it wasn't for that phone call that I
made while setting up the PlayStation
let's see so let's jump over here to
Hannibal takes Edinboro let's see if the
sound is back on here audio device
let me know if y'all can hear that on
the Adam Braille side Oh welcome it's a
comedy at the Knitting Factory
going to Scotland for a month I leave
tomorrow oh I gotta go work yeah this is
that Knitting Factory in uh in Brooklyn
I hosted a show there for a while there
is Cali right there
Cali out in New York I'm trying to see
if any other faces I recognize and yeah
this is show up it was a fun show
it's a host for a while kind of you know
there's a couple blocks what fun we'll
get my hair cut
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
was going on in my head this is 2012
what the [ __ ] is coming back what's
going on see this is a what oh my god I
can't even I'm so
hey DJ DJ bring that [ __ ] right back
real quick what I was doing fine at this
time
I was traveling I didn't know how to
clean up temple there's a little digital
recorder right there I was never at this
this spot watching like this wow look at
this this place is a [ __ ] yo OH
as far as New York comedians don't what
they're probably top 5 in underwear was
that one two three four five man [ __ ]
balding y'all so many goddamn boxes man
I [ __ ] myself so much Wow like is
nothing whoa
Europeans don't [ __ ] with this size of
town like you go to place they don't
have this this is not part of their life
in the bathroom why don't you have
washcloths the [ __ ] you washing your
face with hey Europe get a [ __ ] towel
like this
I happen over to the atom girlfriends
festival I'm going over there cuz you
get better as a comedian we're
performing everyday for a month so don't
still technically have that apartment
I don't live but I sublet it to a friend
because I'm just I'm a bad at closure
apparently and moving who I couldn't
move most of my stuff out of there will
be a lot of performing in us a lot of
fun
everybody say why you concerned with
washcloths be concerned about your
apartment that is you know that's pretty
I mean it's bonkers for me what's up
with these washcloths in my place with
like that but hey human beings are
complicated
Elwood power and even power just sent
one dollar ninety-nine one quid
ninety-nine how do you say that
[Music]
goddamn that was a little that was kind
of wavy let's run that back alright and
I'm gonna use that to take us back to
last of us real quick and we're gonna
play some summoning game since we just
arrived in Scotland it's a perfect time
to get back in here you know
so that's sleep let's sleep
we're gonna go let's sleep right here
let's sleep in my own boom-boom
Oh
there we go
No
okay what do you think light moderate
Percy what a difficulty should I should
I take one thing what do you think very
light with a lighter camera name that's
challenging to moderate let me see
what's gonna be the most but I was
looking I see you don't even know what
type of let's see survivor can I change
it
wait I think I gotta go
I got a I got a uh let's see Marvel now
moderate is smarter you know what I'm
saying off-balance I got to either go
like well I gotta go in let's go
aim and look invert challenge level can
be changed at any time okay option is
difficulty okay you know what I'm a
survivor this definitely goes isn't that
recommended for your first playthrough
yes go go
yes you can change it you can change it
goofy [ __ ]
alright
let's go
all right I'm gonna get back to animal
sex Adam breasts a little bit too slow
for me
so uh anyways let's get into it
so yeah they're like some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
is having it before cozy after [ __ ] kind
of refrigerator what the [ __ ] kind of
fridge is this yo what others have
toilet I was complaining about they
place
she needed her immunity to mean
something okay
starting to buy at home yeah nicely Jack
the first time maybe I just wanted to do
right already see that's what you know
used to get played the first one
he started out talking about some lady
he's already hurt her okay they were
actually gonna make all right something
happen to her okay the only catch is
about the bus out of tow what are you
doing I won't let you take this is true
think of all the lives we'll safe Jesus
Christ Joe what you do what do you do
what do what
Sammy cut back to what you did
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah that's
that's a lot that's a lot
no where's that lino
I totally just ran some tests
I told her
her immunity meant nothing
all right and she believed you you know
what I'm gonna let them figure out a
storyline you know and I'm gonna jump
back into Hannibal take that up girl
so here we are I just got to the flat
and the flat the apartment yeah in the
shower different kind of take a walk to
wash my hands I'm not taking [ __ ] the
[ __ ] type of person is this well I think
this place is owned by a [ __ ] that
likes to inconvenience himself yo I'm in
st. but it's going in on a place that
acts because the refrigerator is small
and the toilet is in a separate room
from the shot which makes sense why you
want to sit in the same sour spot didn't
have the [ __ ] air be up in there and
where you wash you want to [ __ ] the [ __ ]
room should be a separate room the sink
in [ __ ] room and then a shower room with
a sink is is a pretty is a pretty good
good
how much is on everything what all right
I got a horse I got a horse quick update
I have a horse everybody I have a horse
quick update I had a horse y'all
odo they put me on a horse I gotta make
a move okay
now can you all hear - gay
no oh this horse
this horse is oh this always just
created responsible
hey this horses oh man I can't play
tones was that just I hope that guitar
functional
[Music]
and and see if I want CFP
if he plays he plays the guitar
his horse yeah
[Music]
Maya y'all can hear the game but I can't
hit a game break and you know why can't
I
why-why-why hit it high I what about
what about me
[Music]
maybe that
I have no game in my headphone with my
snare
all right buddy what a hella be going so
even cook even cook we need the visuals
artists drop by even cooking the chat
lead visuals artist start out even cook
shout out richer can be airs that out
Amelia Jets supper Amelia Saxon check
that out Zoe lead shout out Frank design
shut up Ashley switowski drop her ass
this what else give the check
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so that was a little bit of a horse
journey and we're gonna take it back to
Hannibal
takes a deep breath all right where were
we
you know that I was in the in the flyer
taking residence he takes values
[Music]
fringe is one of the world's largest
arts festivals there are a huge number
of shows the main program this year
probably has about 900 shows in it the
frame differs from other festivals just
in one fundamental aspect which is sheer
scale it's very very difficult for
anybody who's not been to Edinburgh to
understand just quite how big it is the
city of half a million doubles in
population and the excitement among
zubrin's of the Fringe spills out onto
the streets to bootcamp where it's a
chance for you to kinda hone your skills
as a performance because you get to do
26 shows in a row of the same show it's
exactly the same number of miles as in a
mass and you've got to pace yourself
it's not just about survival it's about
how not the worst possible picture for
that super mental in the process which
unfortunately of people do seem to go a
bit naughty during the course of the
festival it's an experience
I always got a you'd never think about
what you know you just making a goofy
face but then without the foresight for
Mima culture you know what I mean you
just make it a face and then nine years
later a bunch of sixteen year olds
sitting your face Brown never know you
did stand-up comic
[Music]
smells place smells like zebra puss what
do you think would you appreciate my
comedy at this value
no I would dip back into that weird
corner let's blast the music
[Music]
[Music]
nice
hey what's happening thank y'all for
coming to the show it's a lot of shows
in this festival so I appreciate the
cameras mind I got I got hired a bunch
today let's see if you want to see the
stand up march where is it it's not up
anywhere right now so I guess I don't
know we'll put it up online maybe we'll
put it up at Bezos place in the
marketplace when we put it up on my
channel a little bit after Miami nice
drops maybe we'll put it on a website
you'll put it on the website if you want
to see it don't worry my story sucks had
a why'd you get that scar man I was
drunk trying to [ __ ] this factor out of
South Carolina I'm glad I didn't die how
Hannibal died hanging out with some girl
let me see it [ __ ] it a girl
tough way to go out recipes that he's
fetish yo on it describe me easier you
know that comedian he has a towel around
a mic stand my mic a little ready oh
yeah yeah the comedian oh man doing some
real let's jump back to the game
so the thing with
they had a brother
[Music]
drop like shout out there eukaryote
shout out Haley gross
it's okay I got you go on you sure about
what we were talking about earlier
I can't say I've done different I'll
take it to the grave if I have to
silento
[Music]
shoutout Neil druckmann
okay Ellie
whoa Jesus just gave me a heart attack
tried knocking but hey hey what's up
Joel just check it in folks were talking
about how impressed they are with you
all right well you're helping out let's
go okay this is the weirdest thing I've
seen on the Internet sneeze fetish yeah
on an episode of the Eric Andre show
there's this game with it throwing
coffee on Eric Andre
and so I sneeze because of it and then
so is some website this is comedian
Hannibal Buress he sneezes around 40
seconds just sniffles around 45 seconds
there's a sneeze fetish website in the
world
that's weirdest [ __ ] now the type of
sex that we're trying to be
around 10:30 in the morning there's
quite early to try to do stand-up comedy
and I got another show after this is at
11:45
so before I'm 1 o'clock I would have
done two shows today that you actually
have a flat and Edmund a pontiff here is
that it's not right to you did you punch
this one when you're over no why would I
do that but the plan I'm reading is is
very awful the one that I have in this
month that lady I don't know how she
lives like that it's what it is in a
separate room from the sink and shower I
don't understand that at all and his
upsets me so I just I just pee in the
sink when I first kind of somebody was
knocking on my door 9:00 in the morning
nothing who's knocking on my door I
don't know anybody here who is this
let's say who is it
and it God says God is power
[Laughter]
one thing about Edinburgh taxis is that
oh it's guitar time on the game
one thing about Annabelle taxis is that
they they always they knew the town just
they just knew it in a crazy way it was
it was insane like they never had to go
on an app or anything we'll put it in
GPS you could say any little street and
they knew exactly how to get there
so let's go look at that it is guitar
timing is my about to play guitar I
wrote a video game shut up
he's a on the to the core swipe Oh
hold on here what's going on in the
music okay
[Music]
okay
Hey
okay
[Music]
if it there's a guitar hero people have
anything to do with this
all right they just are you upset how do
you feel about this damn this is wait
okay if I ever talk about you
[Music]
trying sometimes you'll succeed to make
this baby
Oh stolen missing parts I have no need
for
[Music]
and I believe I can see here today days
are here with me
[Music]
there you go oh well I'll take what I
can get she's yours no I don't know the
first thing about that I teach you how
to play you did
we'd say that's what do you say tomorrow
night first lesson
okay
okay
did
remember the joke
what is the downside to eating the clock
all right
all right let's go going to the Assembly
Rooms
yeah like the Voskhod 7 esta
drop some in Romania this boys daughter
selfless in Williams you saw disease
ever be safer there that's close
George Street right now I'm just trying
to make sure this isn't right cuz
there's two Assembly Rooms that's all
I'm sayin
but I told him the wrong thing he
brought me to the right suit yeah I
don't know who you are at all do ya give
another tax yeah I'm lost I got I got to
get to the Hannibal I got to get to we
got along all right do y'all know where
you're the balloon and
lady the [ __ ] talk about you know
that they tell me a joke oh wait it's
the cutscene going on over here what's
happening she's probably just trying to
make you jealous I didn't I would never
I'm messing with you man
I don't care get dressed
you're the worst whoa it's kind of
[ __ ] up you did that smells fine
oh now I'm here all right
okay
here we go oh I just mopped on it any Oh
where's your good was that is Joel up
sucks
shut up
it's just about to get up I was you got
everything
yes heads up you're the talk of the town
this morning
what
let me see if I got this right you kiss
Deena all right
she kissed me which triggers have to
call you a not-so-nice word yep Venge
old ekdum are confusing sounds exciting
Maria wants a word with you where is she
diner just about Seth no clue just tell
her you never saw me
nope where's your [ __ ] loyalty excuse
me
Hey
so we're okay right you and Deena and I
are about to have some [ __ ]
interaction
hella cool thanks
Wow look at all these people
a time yeah give this [ __ ] what up
no tell me the banjo how much for the
banjo all right here let me up here
hey Ellie is nobody is my night
where's my knife
hey Jesse oh hi
Hey I think I see some of you
complaining about the echo and at this
point I don't have to tell you can't do
[ __ ] fighting I'm busy playing video
game wanna grab some breakfast
[Music]
what is this something you want to say
to you I don't want to hear what that
big it has to say
do it for me please Seth Seth c'mere how
do you skip the same all right we're
gonna jump right into animal takes a
deep breath and get it going so here we
go and where were we here is weird doing
kind of people you do comedy will be
funny right now well why aren't you
funny right now
why don't you like funny every second of
all time
you don't seem like a comedian because
you you go seem like a comedian cuz you
don't have a flower on your shirt in the
face right then I mean they could know I
was a DC I just did a show me and my
friends go to a bar meet this girl drink
and dance and have a good time she
wasn't even at the show we leave that
place to go to a nice spot it's probably
some people shows man like that felt
good it's like okay I'm done right that
room notes
kind of feel stuck in there is now a lot
more shows man like that's like okay I'm
done right that room kind of feels stuck
in there it's now like a club but you
kind of could dip out like if you leave
that room everybody know you left the
road which is probably that's kind of
tough as an audience member man it's
probably some people that really had to
piss really bad it's not worth it man my
comedy is dope but don't piss yourself
or don't destroy your body forever you
know what I mean just if you feel like
you missed something then go ahead piss
and then if you want to see it I'm here
till all this 26 come back again and
[ __ ] piss right before I don't drink
so much bet you [ __ ] us
right that speech turds yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
sweaty ass that was [ __ ] Scotland is a
weird place one night I was out it was
5:00 in the morning I was talking with
this girl I decided to take a swim after
she is walking away from this is
sometimes you gotta yell to sell sitting
yesterday yeah she just calm down
I don't know maybe I'll yell and make
see how that works they like yelling a
little bit here sometimes you gotta yell
to sell oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna teach a comedy class sometimes
you gotta yell to say give me a thousand
dollars tomorrow before the strain we're
gonna be doing yell to sell got to be at
5 p.m. that'll be my comedy class and
and we'll be doing that so here we go
back into the game and yeah learning a
lot about both of these things
when you go out I want you to trade off
with Tommy and Joel his boys have been
out for far too long where do I meet
them you go to the northwest look at
their scheduled arrive later today
infected recently of course check out
the creek trails I'll need someone else
to cover it Ellie you know the creatures
not really Dina's done it a bunch I'll
have the two of them tape that's all of
that Ellie and I taught you everything
so look I don't know what's going on
with you and Joel Maria guy really cares
about you
and I'm sure he didn't mean to fine yeah
yeah okay okay sorry to pry
be safe thanks yo Dina assignments give
me a minute we get your girlfriend of
the stables peace can I talk to you hey
guys tap it out I think one I wanted one
of them Bobby Orr in the back of the
head he look like one was packing up oh
I just want to say sorry for running off
last night oh this it's okay I totally
get it
I I just I felt bad why because I
started the whole thing
all right let's take it back
Hannibal takes Attenborough
[Music]
[Music]
y'all just missed it they bent her in
the back of the head with a snowball
right after Grad we're not cut out here
we go-oh fight you like for real know
where you live Alex
[Music]
[Music]
okay look at that picture on the cover
don't look at that
[Music]
this is awful though that looks like
somebody's awful today was it did we
have beef was there was it was it what
was it what happened huh
I what was what did i do what did I do
to deserve that I was a cover shot
[ __ ] Facebook photo I look high as
[ __ ] I don't even smoke looking highest
[ __ ] we shot we went to another photo
shoot we did another one we have to do
and we didn't even use they use the
pictures for that inside I need I need
an explanation you know this can't be
the best photo for the cover
I don't smoke we people always think I'm
tired of people I was thinking about
Hannibal you HOT no I'm not hot I'm just
way cooler than you bit while I was
super sweaty on purpose this is what I'm
able to be like yeah people say you hi
cut to me sweaty in the more weeds over
analyze the moment which is not good to
do why you have it sex I'm drunk and
having sex and thinking man this is cool
I'm [ __ ] but if I'm hot I'm having
sex I'm thinking yo why she let me do
this to her what's her relationship with
her father I started doing weird [ __ ]
like counting my strokes and the work
and the tool now to get my state to be
in my first regular comedy gig I hosted
an open mic in my college town it was
poetry music comedy stuff the mouth
without soiling my jeans you believe
yourself to get just a little bit rap
fan I love rap music but rap videos are
weird sometimes they have to be
continued never happen but see what's
going on there and I subscribe one love
Miami
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right we actually have some work to
do
I guess I asked for that huh yep let's
go
wait did I follow OSI time do the corner
back so Jesse wants us to do the creek
trails he's gonna relieve Joel and tano
oh that's nice you a scientist over
there you're gonna like this hour or so
delusional don't be an idiot she's like
that with everybody
don't [ __ ] up your friendship don't [ __ ]
up your friendship don't [ __ ] up your
friendship tonight was crazy I feel
scared
elated anxious it's just gotta sleep it
off all right
morning girls morning
Hey ladies I'll bring him in thank you
alright gonna jump back it's a Hannibal
takes Attenborough here we go
so I saw somebody asked how many shows
it took to go crazy in Edinburgh and I
don't know I think it is uh I was I was
thinking a lot about the whole time
because it's I think my brain likes
variety and likes movement and so I was
used to that at the time it's just Tory
and so doing a show with the same venue
every day at the same time just didn't
it felt kind of constricted but also I
think a part of that was because of I
was very healthy at the time so I think
that type of if I was working out maybe
30 minutes a day and had that kind of
VESA outlet and there's a reset versus
just doing shows and drinking and
hanging out and then doing another show
so I think the situation was part of it
but then also my habits at the time
little part of it too so there's that
let's get back into it but I do
eventually when the world is more
international travel friendly again
maybe next year the week o to go back
and do maybe a three-day run or so and
add about 3/4 shows just to just to get
there again and because it is a special
experience but I don't think I would
want to do
for a month again it'll be a nice week
or so a second video I'm always
wondering what's gonna happen in the
next video so much suspense are they
gonna pour more champagne on these
[ __ ] or somebody gonna bring a towel
or something this story is really what's
gonna happen next he's gonna give bigger
rims for his truck or he's gonna be
comfortable with his regular rims I need
to know the story was so deep I love the
fact that you know you probably shoulder
that kind of you know in just a room so
this is one of these so this is one of
these yeah extra shelves so I would you
know that's how you pick up extra cash
too as you do so there'll be some nights
though some days first show will be at
10:00 11:00 in the morning you do shows
and then you might have a lemon o'clock
show two o'clock interview a five
o'clock show then do your show and there
may be one or two late night shows so
some of these nights I would do about in
between four to six shows sometimes in
some days it would just be only my show
so it's just depended on my happy time
for what was going on with the people
that I in the room here was going on but
people is just people that are not a
part of the comedy show that are out
there they might just hear excerpts and
so the only thing they hear these Oliver
suddenly playing blackjack they hear
[Music]
yeah that's are they no context at all
oh now you gotta show your tits damn she
must have lost a lot what
see mate I do see myself getting burning
out of being here for a month I already
see it you don't comedy doubt today man
but I really just want to go home listen
to my sets and watch Cougar Town Cougar
Town Oh
GVSU Cougar Town
but what is your main impression of the
festival Ranger well it's for what it's
just a lot of shows in the same space is
it there's nothing like this in America
we have some friends festivals that are
on a smaller scale but here's this it's
a it's a lot to just do what our show in
the same room every day for about a
month and it's crazy comedy a Hannibal
we were watching you stay on holiday
doing
[Music]
oh yeah music part of me is kind of
hoping one of my extended family members
dies my mom I got a great thank you I
gotta go back my great aunt died so I
gotta go back it's two days to travel
with 25 two more I'm just thinking of
ways to get out because I didn't I think
I couldn't just bounce I guess I felt I
was like trapped unreasonably so it's
not that serious but I guess in a
different scenario in that you still
feels you know it's far away
it is like the August weather there is
pretty you know about 55 degrees and
raining almost every day I don't like I
just show is going what's going on dude
oh now that crowd work
thanks man that's cool today
that day but you did show so where's
your show oh that's classy alright just
carry on no flood have to show go now
I've just ended up over here I'm not
here to ridicule use this sometimes it's
nice to talk with people to break up the
monotony man I could talk to you and
that's how these stories that I'm tired
of like I was doing the materia and
someone was going alright but I don't
know if you noticed I was kind of dead
in the eyes
[Laughter]
all right let's get back to the game
he's gonna go with the last of us I'm in
some type of barn right now so here we
go uh-oh
give me my horse [ __ ] that's a
good girl
look who's here good
look who decided to join us
yeah yeah and one for you
open it up
settle down shoot
all right you all know the drill
run your routes mock you see it you
already Israel you see you run into
enemy red head redemption right come
back it's like that
be smart about alright get go
[Music]
[Music]
all right great give it up for last of
us to everybody that was last of us to
favourable now PlayStation
[Music]
it's make it smooth some time in England
in May
[Music]
[Applause]
you have that much is it that much of an
inferiority complex with this country
you go ok so here's this bit there was a
show late in life and somebody kept on
yelling out during during a bit and the
show is uh it was wonderful I think the
show started at midnight or something
like that and Levin so crowd is known
for being a drunk crowd at the at the
shows out there at the festival I'll
need to go to water I'll tell you
something about it but there was at the
same
[Laughter]
so I go on to this job in London
I still have Scottish money
[Music]
I just wanna come up and tell a story
day is this what you do would you city
much your life be what is it the peak of
it hey let's go to the comedy show and
every time somebody
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this man wearing a suit is born in
Dillon and I want to work is that isn't
that worth everybody together
I know exactly where I was
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay I've never really because I never
really did any press specifically for
Edinboro so I never talked about this
moment and I think this is a time as a
i-i-i hampton up for the cameras hamming
it up meaning that yeah they were
terrible this crowd was terrible go at
least that handful of people that was
yelling [ __ ] were terrible but i walked
off cuz i was filming an app that made
that made of it under normal
circumstances I probably would have
wrote it out it'd been combative with
them it really let it flat but I walked
off maybe I said have been walking back
[Music]
[Music]
these stairs were yeah
[Music]
oh good that's that's too long of a
shadow man come on that was
[Music]
outside transducer sides and then we
gonna hold on this for a smooth three
seconds I try to like Scotland but it's
not gonna work out my friends is long
when missile witness a month where two
shows why why can I just do three and go
home I don't know the show is this is
the neck
all right go back to the game it's cold
you sure you don't want to do this one
it Suns out and it's warmer can't wait
and you don't want to just tell me I
need to see it what are you doing
wandering around out here babe you're
like the farther south we go the
prettier it's gotten you want to keep
going just drive all the way to Mexico
I've thought about it you can see
Manny's hometown yeah I don't see that
living up to his stories no probably not
you did all this in the dark yes come on
we keep going like this we're gonna be
tired for today's trip his Mel okay
she seemed out of it these past few days
she'll be fine
bee stop being weird you're freaking me
out I'm not being weird careful jumping
over yeah
[Music]
come on let's go hey this bar this bar
you have to run to make it if you can do
it I can do it
you can't all be as graceful as you
barely what is that
you'll be fine it's too high come on
okay all right so memorization like keep
on doing so I miss home so much what
other people going through a struggle in
life they get really cliche they say
stuff I'm taking it one day at a time
I'm just taking it one day at a time you
know who else says everybody cuz that's
how time works
that's the only way to take time what
were you doing in a week out of time
before who are you who taught you how to
do that teach me how to do that I want
to get through this [ __ ] quicker too few
people reach out I'm thinking about
doing stand-up comedy or just a starting
now you will start now in this world you
want to start live stand-up comedy in
you want to start now okay you want to
start comedy when most venues are closed
or at 25 percent capacity best of luck
but I think you know starting right now
something I'm moving this start I'm
moving here to start standing just
you're moving right now to start what
you're moving from one place to another
yeah to start stand-up comedy yeah I
mean and that you know follow your
dreams but yeah tough game to be a right
now I don't like the people say I'll
pray for you and starving you will you
gonna pray for me so you go sit at home
and do nothing anything
while I struggle with a situation that's
what your prayers are you do it
absolutely don't pray for me make me a
sail into something and it's easier to
get cocaine and it is to get an inhale
than this time both a Miss but that's
how time works so you need to go to a
doctor and get a prescription it's great
that just sucks because I have asthma
and it's easier to get cocaine and it is
to get an inhaled at this time also if I
did this again I would have I would
travel if I had to do it again the way I
would've did it back then was figure out
a way to do a show with other people or
something like that having a travel cool
cuz it was the Orion and Nick was his
name it was a two-person filming crew
but they were filming and working on
that so we were hanging but it was still
you know they had they were focusing on
that and it was kind of you know I think
even being filmed
even though as my idea after a while
being filmed the whole time started that
started getting tedious too sometimes I
have ideas and then they're good ideas
and then I'm like wow I still have to do
this like this I started doing this
tonight and I'm already playing video
games after time speak it away let's get
back into it
so last we left you we were walking in
some snow right okay eyes on me
Abby stop looking down you have to go
back this way consider it an opportunity
to work on your fears
I bet I worked my foot up your ass Abby
stop
oh wait wait wait
this way the other no you did a whistle
button on this Bob all right
is it
we made it
holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] City yeah
have you told anyone else I wanted you
to see first
son arm patrol go from town to an
outpost over there a few more outposts
in between
electricity guns what about the rest it
it's a lot of people he's not the run-up
I can figure it out let's go okay
assuming he's in there how do we get to
him we can corner one of the patrols and
get confirmation and then I don't know
maybe find a way to lure him out yeah
yeah okay
I'm sure they'll be happy to offer that
information well then we make them you
hear yourself okay what do you want to
do
all right finally got it you know it's a
three-hour thank y'all for coming to
show here quickly a few rules about the
snow it's a weird Rome especially if you
over there you have to take a piss so if
you do absolutely have to piss do a
dance across the stage cuz I don't want
that over my show over your head cuz
then you'll see to show you like oh yeah
he was alright but I shouldn't have
pissed myself piss myself you think I
like about the UK is the concept of bank
holidays I like that bank holidays this
is holiday cuz people get tired
sometimes
just have a few bank holidays how many
will have this year eight I'm gonna have
next year I guess years ago two guys are
in the bank said hey how about we just
closed the banks on Monday and then suit
everybody oh she's mad she's mad over
here she's mad over here what's going on
hold up she something does happen
sometimes his habit she got mad and then
she just jumped off so I think I'm about
to I gotta go square up damn I gotta
watch these cutscenes so I know she's
mad about yeah if you are watching I'm
trying to end it all just in the morning
with $2.00 with a suicide shout-out
Justin Morgan oh yeah Daniel what was
that hold up
oh man I don't give a [ __ ]
stun enemies
oh yeah no enemies yet this is my my my
old enemy right now moving while aiming
I'm not there yet I don't need this yet
but tell me how about the kill myself in
this game the oven is there every time
all right let me go
[Music]
let's go up here alright so
keep dududududududududu
[Music]
I don't give a [ __ ] the whole thing I
just read the news Cinda see the link to
the stream to your mama in the chat the
link to the stream in your mama tell us
Irma you know tell us to tell you mama
sent me ten dollars and I'll say shout
out the joseline alright next next
alright alright okay I got a move past
this phase in mine you know what let's
go back to Hannibal takes a
cuz everything else is closed I like
that I like that holiday because there's
no baggage attached to it because in
America we have holidays but all of them
have baggage Memorial Day while you have
this day off please take a moment to
think about all these dead [ __ ]
no I want to think about damn
[ __ ] I just want to hang out
with my family why don't you make damn
[ __ ] day won't you make that or
doing a workday
Christmas has baggage I think the story
of Jesus has holes in it no pun intended
and pun intended work for free hey guys
protect me and I'll give you all the
free wine you want do I make that [ __ ]
out of water
humble Jesus show up what you telling me
that one of Jesus murders didn't have a
moment of clarity and say hey instead of
killing this guy why don't we at 11:40
so psyched to see him do and I was set
man
maybe knife
drinking beer really not excited about
it at all just leave that sad beer
drinking shy Jesus all right should have
stopped after that sip instead of
waiting five more years to stop drinking
two dailies and gonna be nice and and
look at this [ __ ] just staring off Siri
Siri I'm talking to you yo look at this
yeah damn it just like I guess I have to
drink this era somebody would a gun at
the back of your head to drink this beer
Jesus Christ was such an unhappy year at
11:40 so pleased that see him dude
and I was set man it'd be nice just
picking it up matt has no smile no smile
at all this is like looking off just
like
[Music]
I was really upset about waiting around
and then the comedy Pepitone lady we're
gonna jump back into this game and see
if we can get over our suicide problem
let's go nope not there not today not
today okay yeah whistles listen don't do
it don't do it okay
all right all right here let's go down
to follow Oh
oh I thought break this out
Oh leave that fax yeah
even though
you have a sale photos for the [ __ ] up
options let's see how you think
they take the pretty
yeah
okay
[Music]
[Music]
edinburg the festival itself is more of
an endurance test and now I'd rather
just go watch shows that's more where I
am in the fest what it is for I enjoy
performing everywhere but the fest was
is a gram I enjoy performing everywhere
but the first was a is a gram for two
for 15
we're okay
I make you know I finally been up early
and I planned out my date and it's nice
that's the good part of the train just
watch the shows and I think watching
other shows makes me less bored with my
own so
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you deal with fatigue that
happens around a third week or so I used
to drink my way through it but then you
have to do that psychological flip like
you've made the decision to do this with
your life yeah that's when I change the
show up yeah and make up new jokes that
just died I want to mix it up a lot and
so that is a big way of mixing it up and
maybe find some different stuff so let's
see we'll see how it goes or not [ __ ] it
most people I know got iPhones and
drawing some blackberries I get weirded
out when I see somebody with a flip
phone hey that's not some real phone
right you're gonna use that phone call -
the rivers always racist comments dude
is me beta racist and masturbated the
same
are you working on anything right now I
mean always working on things yeah no
it's just I find it weird it's a very I
always say Hollywood is a whole lot of
nothing everybody's always what's next
oh you suppose an idea what are you
working what do you do what you want to
do listen I want to tell jokes yeah yeah
and then what are you like in the future
what are you I haven't watched this
before most of the moon at the beginning
I haven't seen this scene so I'm
watching good jokes
[Laughter]
[Music]
the two are there we go over set list is
like improvised stand up show will you
get five topics and you just have to
come up with a set on the spot like
right on stage it's nice to break out of
the stand up and do different things
just to have your mind work in a
different way Spain the game stay within
the conceded is your real set this is
always nice to do alright we're gonna
jump back in the game and see if we can
defeat the cliff
alright let's go yes life is a nightmare
but you can overcome it
keep going don't jump off that cliff go
climb up these rocks Oh keep your eyes
on the prize no keep going
left alright let's go this way
[Music]
they're matching his mob do I need to
turn it off I might need to turn off the
survivor you know what guess let's do
this with a lot of combat yeah okay I
need some resources
like the restart of the current five all
right all right we got to go back to
Hannibal sakes Attenborough and check
how the rest gets one laugh but it makes
it much more difficult for you from the
men on stay loose
human men and women are different we are
different people should stop smoking
vegetarians are weird
rap music they say dumb stuff women are
different some people are fat McDonald's
they're still around
da-da-da-da-da-da-da oh my gosh some are
car smart constant prayers I'm slightly
nervous but that's just so I want to do
well
so first let us do some observational
humor men and women are different we are
a lot different people should stop
smoking vegetarians are weird
grab music they say dumb stuff women are
different some people are fat McDonald's
they're still around Delta Delta Delta
smart car smart car smart cars
smart cars public transportation public
transportation homeless people homeless
people homeless people they always wear
[Applause]
[Applause]
I know why do people get so weirded out
when they see me for incident just like
me I can have the most efficient
threesome ever
so the thing that they the reason why
I'm an atheist all right find out later
why I'm an atheist after we play some
more last of us to where we left left
here you know speaking of atheism I've
been committing suicide on in the game
just a seed where we go whatever take a
bubble and it turns out that you come
right back as yourself with an
opportunity to future mistakes just like
so
[Music]
okay easy now think this trick is it's
like a lighthouse no look just like a
nice trail if you're trying to
[Music]
the ham will take sad umbrella last we
left talking about eight years oh so
let's get back into that because great
Cadence's make my dick hard
[Laughter]
great Cadence's and rhythm my dick heart
you speak with passion makes my dick
hard so I was going to start this guy
was speaking really well and uh how I
started you know she was erotic it was
smooth and so I was at the church I had
to go off into a dark corner
echo echo echo echo echo echo echo echo
echo echo echo echo echo echo echo echo
echo echo echo echo echo echo as you can
see here earlier anybody that's been in
the chest for you right there anybody
that was had a sound complaint that's
for you and so I was at the church I had
to go off into a dark corner echo echo
echo echo echo echo echo echo echo echo
echo echo echo echo echo
[Music]
everyone shows here at the fringe shows
get review on the star system and people
called us out on their posters and I go
see souls and I like some sit so I think
that my opinion is very valid in comedy
reviews so I want to go review some of
the shows I have but I gives toes
Sabbath's like you either get seven
songs on those stars that's it
I'm a man of extremes and that's how I
live life let's see one of my favorite
songs that I saw was Sami Jam Randy this
is a really good show I enjoyed it so
he's gonna give it
seven stars for Sammy giant red no stars
no stars no stars didn't see that T to
see that didn't see that P Johansson
very funny comic I worked with him in
Amsterdam I did not see his show but
early on in the festival
while we were out for drinks his wife
did flash of Medina to me three times so
for that seven stars that is the seven
star show right there seven goddamn
stars congratulations
boom seven stars seven seven seven stars
for spanked seven stars
[Music]
what else have you seen you seen
anything else at the friend so far you
know out that I wasn't I was just using
yesterday at the segue into what I've
seen I want to see the ugly duckling now
you're not strong you have to be as a
grown man to go see the ugly duckling by
yourself what are the box office
one fugly duck the duck can I say one
and one shout not just me just one me
just wanna don't man watch an ugly
duckling now say now watch the duck
house flapping and sit I talk to people
after where they said they thought I was
either reviewer or a pedophile or a
reviewer talk about that second act I
wanna see this playing New York all
Sleep No More it's not a regular play
what you sit in the audience why so I
fought it in that room was this clean so
far but stop being a [ __ ] and then go
to the store and give me some juice I
said oh [ __ ] what's happening whiskey I
wasn't ready to give up on a night well
why were you so drawn to me cuz I didn't
think I didn't think you would talk like
this she just kept on going
Hannibal let's build this up making a
special experience you're gonna [ __ ] me
all night I want you to [ __ ] me all
night no no not at all that's not
happening
well how long you gonna [ __ ] me for
between 7 and 21 minutes but she talked
so much it was a horrible she just kept
on talking it was the first time in my
life ever came fast out of spite I gotta
come go to bed and then sleep off the
effects of your personality cuz you put
me in a funny mental place and now I
probably have a weird dream because of
you and that brings me to my date Monday
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday sick
cells left that's it they try to give me
the hata so I said yet
[Laughter]
[Music]
it was going out of folks what's
happening just a little of walking in
material get the crowd warmed up early
anybody in from Connecticut I'm doing I
saw child warm-up all right
speaking of warm-up it's pretty cold
outside and it's cold in hell so let's
just check out what's going on with last
of us too
Chris Berg how you Chris Merck in the
chat can you grab the guide me through
this
like
we're not eat my footsteps of somebody
else
I don't know what's real anymore clip
don't get this gap
[Applause]
[Music]